today in this video i will share with
you what the jobs are that in 2030 will
be in very high demand and also what the
jobs are that in the future likely will
not be needed that much anymore and all
of this is not just based on my gut
feeling but it's based on a study from
boston consulting group called the
future of jobs in the era of ai so let's
look into it let's first better
understand their methodology indeed
they're looking at two factors workforce
demand and workforce supply let's start
with the latter so for the workforce
supply they're looking at graduates from
the education system from university
they're looking at migration and ad
retirement rate and for the workforce
demand they're looking at technology
advancement advancements and artificial
intelligence they look at efficiency
increases that can be expected in the
different industries and they also look
at the effect of covet and they're
specifically a modeling the effects of
all these factors work for supply and
demand until 2030.
and the first name may be
counterintuitive takeaways the contrary
to popular demand actually in 2030 it's
not the case that ai eats up all the
jobs but actually there will be a
shortfall of the workforce so there are
not enough people that actually are
needed for the jobs net over all the
different job categories this is 6.7
million people that are missing in the
u.s and 1.3 million people that are
missing in germany so let's start with
you as what are the job families with
the highest demand in 2030 according to
boston consulting group and i will first
talk about job families and later in
this video at the end also share some
very very specific positions in these
families that will be missing let's
start with number five and these are
roads in architecture and engineering
number four is business and financial
operations so professionals working in
business roads and specifically in
finance roads i trust this is good news
for all of us consultants who surely
usually are quantitatively inclined have
a certain analytical understanding which
definitely will be helpful for these
types of careers nexus healthcare
practitioners and technical support i
also believe that this is no surprise
all of these things will just be
replaced by ai and surely with our aging
society the need for health care will
increase next is management white collar
management leadership roads this i found
to be actually quite interesting because
this is an area where i often hear that
i will replace all these positions
apparently it's not so much the case at
least not until 2030. last but not least
by far the most significant demand even
twice the magnitude of for instance
management is computer and mathematics
so likely these are the software
engineers the professionals potentially
developing all these systems of the
future here either then maybe maybe not
met replace any of these jobs surely
these people will be needed there's a
career that will require quite formal
education so if you are willing to
invest in yourself and incline for these
types of topics go ahead but now let's
look at the other side of the medal what
are the positions where actually we'll
have too many people working with these
types of qualifications in the future
and here on number three it's
transportation and material moving so
surely can very much understand why
these things might be automated in the
future many trains might drive without
train drivers cars will drive without
drivers so many people operating these
types of vehicles will likely not be
needed anymore in the future number two
of the positions with the most
significant workforce surplus it's
actually food preparation and service so
apparently these types of roads are
expected to be much more automated as
well potentially mod for them declining
trust that makes sense also in the light
of food delivery quick food delivery
services and all number one the road
that in the us will be most likely not
needed at least not to the extent that's
right now in the future is office and
administrative support so i think here
the takeaway is that these are the more
simple business roles the support type
of business roles that maybe don't
really require this high level of
qualification as for instance the
management leadership roles also the
business operations finance roles we
just talked about so yes if you work in
business and your qualifications are not
that high you're not really specialized
not really experienced this might be a
problem this is a job family that will
be at risk in the future and let's now
switch to germany and surprising or
maybe not surprising the jobs that will
be in high demand they're actually quite
similar then in the u.s the numbers are
of course a bit different a bit smaller
due to the lower population in germany
there's one noticeable exception though
and this is that people working in
educational instruction and library will
be needed so location professionals are
in quite demanding germany they seem to
be missing in the future if we look at
the job families where there will
actually be a workforce surplus in the
future i think it's pretty interesting
that number three we find construction
and extraction the common narrative in
eastern germany is that actually there
is a big lack of qualified people
working in these sectors but apparently
here the exports of boston consulting
group are predicting that this will
change in the future office and
administrative support we just talked
about interestingly enough on number one
is production but they're expected to be
more people available in the workforce
that i actually needed also this i think
quite interesting in germany there's a
lot of talk about these people actually
being in demand and missing about a need
for these qualified blue collar workers
apparently at least in the future this
might not be the case anymore largely of
course likely also due to automation now
the study from boston consulting group
even went one step further because now
they double clicked into these job
families totally distill the tangible
positions that likely will be in demand
or not that much in demand in the future
now let me share the top five positions
for the us and for germany on number
five it's engineers i don't think it's
that surprising given the other figures
that we just saw and number four it's
medical doctors i think these also very
much in line with what we just heard or
number three business operations
specialists and a number two and this is
i think what was quite interesting
senior executives really senior leaders
of large organizations this is what will
be in high demand in the us only
followed by on number one computer
occupations and if you look at the
figures for germany it's more or less
the same story only with teachers
stepping in actually on number three so
what does this mean for us what does
this mean for you given that i know that
at least a good portion of you have a
professional background in consulting i
think roads like these so senior
executives and business operations
specialists are roads that you will be
very well equipped after you've spent a
couple of years working for one of the
leading consulting firms like mckinsey
bcg bain and the likes so i think this
is actually quite good news but now you
let me know what is your perception on
this topic let me know in the comments
about your opinion would very much
appreciate your view if you took any
value out of this video at all destroy
the like button for the youtube
algorithm and subscribe to the channel
as always big big thanks to the members
of the channel thank you for your
contributions my name is heinrich i
release weekly videos here on the
channel so see you again next week